Esta es la tercera noche consecutiva en
el que los servicios de rescate no
solamente de la ciudad de dni pero sino
del resto de Ucrania realizan labores
buscando sobrevivientes en ese edificio
que está a mis espaldas conocido en esta
ciudad del centro sur del país como la
Muralla China por su longitud este
recibió un impacto de misil durante ese
ataque masivo lanzado por Rusia el
pasado sábado a varias ciudades de
Ucrania que también tuvo como objetivo
estructuras de la infraestructura
especialmente eléctricas pero que tuvo
sus mayores consecuencias aquí en este
edificio donde nos encontramos según las
autoridades cuarenta personas han
fallecido se han encontrado fallecidas
hasta el momento 75 quedaron heridas
pero todavía hay 34 personas que están
desaparecidas que estarían bajo esos
escombros y el presidente
que dijo que no cesarían
este trabajo hasta que encuentren a la
última persona este esto es ataque es
uno de los tantos que se ha llevado a
cabo contra infraestructura civil desde
que comenzó la guerra el 24 de febrero
del año pasado y tanto el presidente
como diferentes personalidades en
Ucrania han llamado a que Rusia sea
investigado por crímenes de guerra no
solamente por este ataque sino por
muchísimos otros más pero este ha vuelto
a despertar la conmoción y la
indignación de los ucranianos es que con
el pasar de las horas se conocen
historias humanas de esas personas que
fallecieron aquí entre ellas hoy se
conocía una niña de 15 años bailarina
con todas las ilusiones del mundo otras
dos voluntarias doctoras y dentistas que
estaban aquí también y así otras
personas cada una con una historia cada
vez más conmovedora que tiene
entristecido al resto del país